[Music]
foreign
we have already done a video on the 15
biggest flying Kaiju do check that out
in the channel but here now we will
showcase the 15 biggest flying movie
monsters that are not Kaiju but seen in
live action movies and shows so let's
get to it
at 15 we have the philbies from Lord of
the Rings these are large winged
creatures with a menacing and Sinister
appearance they often appear and are
described as dragon-like with bat-like
wings and a reptilian body they have
sharp claws a long tail and a roundish
head Feld bees are primarily used by the
Nazgul as teeth and aerial mounts the
ring raids being Spirits bound to
sauron's will needs these creatures to
travel swiftly and strike fear into
their enemies all around Middle Earth
at number 14 we have the great Eagles
also from Lord of the Rings The Great
Eagles are a noble race of birds that
were created by the Lord of The Valor
they are among the oldest creatures in
Middle Earth and are considered the
mightiest of birds they possess great
intelligence strength and wisdom they
are described as having silver feathers
Keen eyesight and Powerful beaks and
Talons they are often called upon times
of great need or to fulfill specific
tasks
number 13 Castle guadal from the 1982
movie called Q because of guadal is an
Aztec deity transported to New York City
by an ancient Aztec gods it says the top
of the Chrysler Building waiting for the
birth of its Offspring it is a colossal
serpent with draconic features including
slender limbs dark orange scales and
massive Wings its mouth is a big devoid
of teeth while its feet are done with
elongated fingers tipped with razor
sharp talons the Wings Bear resemblances
of feathers of fleshy fringes but are
neither
number 12 the jabber walk sit in Alice
in Wonderland the jabbawock is depicted
as a monstrous dragon-like creature with
a menacing presence it has a large scaly
body a long neck and a reptilian head a
dawn with sharp fangs and twisted horn
crowns its eyes are often portrayed as
glowing with an eerie light the
jabberwock's body is covered in dark and
rugged scales giving it a menacing and a
formidable appearance it is often
associated with Darkness chaos and
embodiment of fear
number 11 the great protector from Shang
Chi the great protector Bears
resemblance to an Eastern Chinese dragon
with white scales and reddish highlights
the great protector possesses the
ability to control and manipulate water
creating solid water constructs she was
able to create giant tentacles of water
forming a giant water pit in the air to
trap the dweller in darkness although
she was initially shown to be more
powerful than her main enemy she was
later almost killed by the latter
number 10 the greatly enough tourists
seen in avatar The Great Leon Optics
also known as torub is a gigantic aerial
Predator native to the Moon of Pandora
it is the apex predator of Pandora's
skies and holds a significant cultural
and spiritual significance to the
indigenous Nabi people its body is
covered in vibrant blue and black
feathers giving it a striking appearance
it is also yellowish and radish the
creature has a sleek and muscular
physique built for Swift flights and
precise maneuverability
number nine drogon drogon is one of the
three dragons featured in a television
series Game of Thrones he is the largest
and the most aggressive of Daenerys
targaryen's dragons his name after
Daenerys late husband called Robo he is
a massive dragon with black scales red
eyes and Powerful Wings his size and
strength makes him a fearsome sight to
behold as he matures his scales become
thicker and harder providing him with
increased protection
number eight the bull Dragon also known
as the male dragon or the Alpha dragon
it is the main antagonist of the 2002
action film called Reign of Fire he is
the alpha male and the leader of his
race as well as the sole surviving male
at the end while all other Dragons Were
females the bull dragon has a shot snout
long head horns small chick horns and
large lower jaw horns being the oldest
and presumably the last remaining male
in existence he had grown considerably
massive
number seven the dweller in darkness
seen in Shang Chi he is a draconic alien
with humongous Wings a very long neck
similar to that of a felby's and long
Tentacles from its back primarily black
with translucent red in its wings he has
a fearsome mall and a spiked head he is
the leader of the Soul Eaters and can
imitate as well as control minds or at
least manipulate them to his own ends
the dweller in darkness could grow
without stop as long as he has souls to
devour
[Music]
number 6 Dragon storm introduced in
Transformers The Last Knight dragonstorm
is a mechanical creature with a
dragon-like appearance and is the
combined form of the Knights of iacon he
has an imposing body covered in metallic
armor and intricate mechanical details
his three heads is adorned with fears
looking features including sharp fangs
and glowing red eyes Dragon Storm's
wings are expansive and Powerful giving
him the ability to fly and even chase
after aircrafts
number five the Leviathan these are
cybernetically augmented creatures and
used for combat and troop transport by
the gitari armies under Terrace's
command seen in Avengers these are large
creatures with Serpentine whale-like
bodies and massive teeth they are clad
and almost completely in armor and is
outfitted with large fin like blades but
also with anti-gravity devices and
grappling hooks for chitari passengers
to rapple into battle
number four vegar this one comes from a
show The House of the Dragon this
massive Beast is the biggest dragon at
that time she is Vega and is one of the
original dragons of aegon Targaryen the
only one that is still surviving out of
the series vegar is massive around twice
the length of the bull Dragon therefore
putting her around 250 to 300 feet or 76
to 91 meters long and visibly very old
and aged she is barely yellow or
greenish in color and the only one
without horns on her head her wings are
huge with reddish tins and can cover
entire villages
number three skytulu skytulu is the main
antagonist of the 2010 Canadian horror
film called altitude in the movie A
group of friends flying in a small plane
to see a concert are hit with a
mysterious turbulence that traps them in
a nightmarish alternate Dimension filled
with endless skies and inhabited by a
giant identical monster a very large
cephalopod-like bees with Lamprey like
mouths and lined with sharp teeth with
over 50 long thin tentacles
number two smog seen in the movie The
Hub of the Desolation of Smaug he
resides in the Lonely Mountain also
known as Erebor which is once a thriving
Dwarven Kingdom he is a dragon of
colossal size and power he is depicted
as a fire breathing winged creature with
alarm and synonymous body covered in
thick scaly armor small scales are
predominantly red and gold giving him a
fearsome and Majestic appearance
and number one the Celestial Dragon the
Celestial Dragon is the primary
protagonist and a dragon that appeared
in the 2007 Korean fantasy movie called
Dragon Wars a d-war in this original
appearance the Great Serpent is
described as a brown to gray blue scale
Cobra like imogi after its
transformation into an ethereal being it
takes the form of a gigantic Eastern
Dragon and flies without wings this is a
movie monster that isn't technically at
Kaiju but has the size that is
comparable to one
so those are the 15 biggest flying
monsters that are not gaijus so I hope
you have enjoyed watching this video do
hit the like button for support and
subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates and new
videos here on this channel take care
fam